I don't know I don't have it all I think
I would have to have a surrogate Kim
Kardashian when she had one of her
babies was at the Met Gala the day
before and then she just like flew in to
like pick up the baby like a coffee
order and like that's so cool to me
drive-thru yeah ex that's what can I get
a ventti iced child you know and like
that's so cool wait I heard you talking
about that you would have a baby with
Jeff is that all [__] um it's pretty
much [__] but it did kind of open my
mind to the idea of having a kid with a
friend through a surrogate and like
co-parenting as friends you
know I'm just toxic and I I I I'm not
that's a lie I'm kind of reformed toxic
but you know if I couldn't find someone
that I was like so in love with wanted
to have a kid and really felt that like
we could raise it in harmony that is
always you know you know what you're
describing to me as like Camp
counselors you know me and a friend were
looking after a
kid it doesn't seem like you're so right
it doesn't you're so cuz that's about
all I have in me you you and and Jeff
are just platonic yes that's like my
best best friend no but I feel like I
feel like it's like that on your part I
think that he would be more based on
what I've seen like on the internet it
seems like he's just saying it's all
platonic but he would be more if you
would give him a chance I guess I'll
never know um and I you know well you
could know if you really wanted to know
yes I just I think there is something to
be said about like valuing a friendship
almost more than that you know and
valuing a a a friendship that has sexual
tension well I mean that pays the bills
you know what I mean the people love a
slow burn they love to watch it they you
know but uh that's what I think I see
when I'm looking at that yeah I mean I
I'm no stranger to monetizing something
of that nature so it's that people in
the chat think that you'd be a great mom
that's so nice thank you chat yeah well
why don't you adopt somebody that's
watching today oh my God I would love to
adopt I would love to pull like an
Angelina and Brad and adopt like 53 kids
as well and not newborns like older
people that you can get along with and
talk oh my God at least like at least
above the age of like four I just think
the new newborns are idiots they're so
useless but if you want that same
newborns are idiots they're such [__]
babies crybabies but you know what what
people don't talk about and you should
think about cuz if you want that same
kind of nurturing feeling yeah people
and and they don't have you want you
want to bring in somebody who doesn't
have parents nothing adopt a senior
citizen wellow I've never thought about
that you should adopt an elderly person
whose entire family has passed away no
an old person you can roll them and it's
not a stroller it's a wheelchair but
it's you can and you can so Howie when
are you ready to sign the
paper you want to adopt
me
[Music]
he